[Musique]
ça non pas de panique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous mènent en europe ça va être génial
je vais profiter du voyage passé du
temps avec mjt hyper solide et du coup
c'est ce qui fait ma valeur non non
c'est parce que je voulais dire c'est
bon de charlie je crois que je lui plais
vraiment c'est génial ça me rappelle 30
janvier
quelle joie de pouvoir enfin tu
rencontres et spider man
non nick fury habille toi on va faire un
tour
j'ai l'impression que nick fury à
détourner nos vacances
ces normes
thaddée dont peter mais on a une mission
est ce que tu vas assuré
tu es tout seul
des amis en désordre nuit
c'est quoi ton plan
je te conseille de pâtes en mêlée
[Musique]
c'est celui là ces genres un mélange de
thor et d'iron man on est loin de spider
man et tu lui trouve quoi spiderman ni
protègent le quartier il un costume qui
tue et je respecte grave ça va lozère